what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpour and although it's hard to
wait two weeks to get a chapter rather
than one week this chapter was a big one
in many ways we got huge reveals and
some very important moments so be sure
to stay tuned for that if you enjoy
seeing these One Piece reviews and want
to keep them coming make sure to smash
that like button until it's blue and
share this video if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future want these reviews and if
you want early access to one piece
reviews and other reviews on the channel
you can follow our podcast and we offer
audio on Spotify Apple podcasts or
wherever else you listen to podcasts
links in the description keep in mind
there will be detailed spoilers since we
are talking about the latest chapter in
one piece now without further ado let's
jump into this interesting chapter this
chapter is called family trouble again
referring to kaido's family at his son
the one piece community has been
obsessed over who this could be
ever since we figured out that yong KO
had won and I even had comments on
videos of people saying it was cut akuti
well we clearly will find out more about
this mysterious and also fascinating
family in this chapter the chapter
starts with anoche who is absolutely
beaming he has ladies around him and
were told he has a calm mind finally in
his mind everything went according to
plan
denying scabbards have been taken care
of their plans were foreseen and stopped
and now their ghosts will finally vanish
from his nightmares of course we know
that this is not in actuality the case
thanks for a few things like keenham own
accidentally giving Kajol the wrong
information Yoshino actually being the
loyal den doodle in disguise and all of
the other members who showed up to join
the alliance things are worse for orochy
than he could have imagined the traitor
contro has yet to arrive and tell him
the updated info and the Cellucci and
the rest have been lulled into a false
sense of security I've said in previous
chapters that the element of surprise
would be the best bet for our boys since
it would be too much in my view to
expect our guys to be too Yong ko and
their crews in a straightforward way
Kaito was super careful back in the day
and was ready when Odin planned to catch
him off guard but this time
doesn't look like they'll be ready they
may be happy drunk and then get
blindsided by our boys most of who are
wearing beasts pirate disguises this
seems to be a recurring pattern when
fighting yong-chol since they also tried
to defeat big mom in the past when she
was vulnerable not when she was at her
strongest I like this aspect of the
series because you don't have Luffy
acting like Goku who helps his enemies
reach 100% of their potential even when
he could have defeated them earlier in
one piece there can be much more
strategy involved we jump back to our
team in onigashima where our samurais /
pirates / mink raid has begun our boy ki
naman is leading the eastern troops then
judo is leading the southern troops and
a total number of men exceeds 5,000 much
more fighters and Odin had back in the
day but Kaito is also weaker than and
didn't have an alliance with big mom
either we jump to laufes with the other
red scabbards in his submarine we get a
map outlining exactly where everyone is
remember kaido's castles in the back so
as kit and luffy probably cause trouble
at the main entrance we'll have three
different teams preparing to cache the
enemy off guard including loss team
which is gonna make use of his devil
fruit power in order to create a new
path that would have not been possible
for practically anyone else he's pretty
much going to use his epic room ability
to teleport the men where they need to
be I really like loss outside the box
thinking here then we jump to conjure Oh
cue the boos for this traitor
I bet conjurer would absolutely hate it
if everyone just smashed the like button
on this video right now chondros got
moment loss gate tied up and is dragging
him along he's supposed to meet with
orochy
but it's his first time there and he
miscalculated how complicated it would
be these pirates are attacking him
because as far as they know he's still
an enemy even though he has momonosuke
tied up which does sort of signal that
he's a bad guy but the beasts parts
probably attack first and ask questions
later kanjar-ro has to beat these guys
while washing momonosuke until he
finally gets to Adachi no easy task but
it serves him right
momonosuke sees a dagger on the ground
and it is implied that he might somehow
pick it up perhaps with his hands that
are tied up behind him so that he can
slowly start cutting the rope or even
stab
Kandra keep in mind momonosuke made an
extremely manly promised that he would
free himself and handle chondral so he's
trying to find a way to do just that
rather than being someone who's helpless
and needs to be saved we jump to the
beast pirates party and people are
having a great time eating drinking and
hollering bad guys clearly have fun
times too but I think some of the stuff
you can notice here is the excess so
much food so much alcohol so much
architectural luxury it really drives
home the contrast between the majority
of one oh and this top 1% elite which
can be super wasteful while others are
starving to death we are told that the
enemy forces are still unaware of our
army of roughly 5000 this is actually
working out great for now because we all
know that on a full stomach and after a
bunch of drinking the last thing you
want to do is fight to the death you'd
rather just enter a sushi coalmine fall
asleep somewhere like that guy who keeps
sleeping everywhere in Tower of God we
get to see some fun you and improved
inventions like Frankie's Rhino
motorcycle and Commander choppers
operating a tank the girls are impressed
and joined chopper in the tank it's like
the one-piece equivalent of a Ferrari
then we get some classic one-piece
hilarity jimbe lets us know that luffy
left to stop kid from causing a scene
and everyone knows that luffy is
definitely gonna get spotted and be the
one to cause a scene then Zorro knowing
Luffy went to make sure he's discreet
but like us the straw hats immediately
realized that he's gonna get lost for
sure we know Luffy is anything but
discreet and that Zorro is the worst
with directions and it's amazing how for
example Zoro's bad since the direction
has been there since pretty much the
beginning of the series but it just
doesn't get old even after almost 1000
chapters gotta hand it to Oda we see
Sanji's own quirk his simple after women
shine through he asks Nami for them to
rendezvous in the battlefield and you
really can't blame him for acting like
this after Nam E's outfit change and of
course we have the ladies chopper and
hop in the tank but there's no room for
the extremely jealous Angie Franky
probably appreciating Robins outfit as
well asks her to ride on his back but
Brook the mad lad he is takes her spot
Franky explains that he was obviously
inviting Robin but Brook
says that I ride along between guys' and
bad we're really getting some time for
the crew and their dynamics to shine and
I love it
I'm impressed that all that can continue
to give everyone great moments even as
the crew has become pretty big at this
point
Frankie is going to the back of the
island to station the vehicles while
commander chopper enjoys his tank in his
commander position and of course
Sanji tries to get Robin to ride on top
with him but alas she passes no luck for
our Sanji this time but in the spirit of
a true Simplot snot lose hope we get a
full body shot of Jim Bay and Robin and
I know I'm being repetitive but Wow keen
m1 and Oda are geniuses for coming up
with these beast outfits for the ladies
is it bad that I'm as excited about
these outfits as the battles Jim Bay
notices that the crew is as lively as
ever and there's a nice bonding moment
between him and Robin he fears that
taking the situation too lightly can be
dangerous and Robin is relieved to hear
such mature words since she's usually
the only mature one in the crew I didn't
even catch this on my first reading but
there does appear to be someone watching
these two from the bushes he or she is
nothing gonna pop up soon enough and
reveal themselves but let me know who
you think it is could it be a huge
game-changer like Idol son or just some
passing by Beast pirate for the meantime
we jump Tokaido who has finally face to
face with the flying six headliners ulti
is as unfiltered as ever and Sasaki is
arrogant calling everyone but Kaito his
underling Qaeda wants to introduce the
Tobi rope pole to big mom but after big
mom finishes changing and Wow it seems
like she really takes her time and
getting ready we can really get a sense
of how gigantic black Maria is here her
head not even fitting into the panel and
we see how Jack towers over someone like
Drake and height I really like the
moment where Kaito sort of apologizes
for keeping them waiting and ulti just
fires back immediately that it was
annoying no fear from her and I love it
these guys have their own fun dynamics
as page 1 is constantly trying to make
ulty censor herself we then learn more
about the inner relations within the
Beast pirate ranks All Star King
actually summoned these guys but had to
use kaido's names because the guys would
ignore the orders of an all-star clearly
the flying sexes aren't the type to just
fall in line
they are ex-pirate captains it seems
that who's-who ant a sake are
particularly unlikely to follow all star
orders which makes sense in Sasaki
literally just said that he's only down
to drink with Kaito and everyone else's
an underling
we have Eagles clashing and the politics
of it all is very entertaining I love
seeing King too since I think he's the
strongest of all Allstars and I really
want to see more of him in action King
points out that the flying six like
Sasaki want to become all stars even
though he's doubtful that they have what
it takes
bow Wong a headliner and seemingly Kaito
secretary who's taken the flying
squirrel smile fruit lets us know the
schedule we're gonna get the all-stars
and master fuku Taku Jo the leader of
auto chase Ninja squad to make a toast
and then Kaito and Lord or Chi are gonna
make speeches I hope we get that since
I'd love to see what kind of speech
Kaito would make to his warriors and
then we'll get the arrival of the big
mom pirates ship probably carrying very
important figures from the big mom
family perhaps they are the ones that
spotted Robin and jimbe the two Yong
chol will then and I quote announce the
biggest pirate alliance in the world and
quote the hype is real and if that
wasn't enough
Kaito is also gonna make a really
important announcement and really is
emphasized
so Oda is definitely building huge hype
around this news kind of is acting out
of character and keeping a secret since
he believes it would bring confusion if
he revealed a secret now Kaito then
tells the tobe ropo to bring back his
idiot son Yamato who disappeared today
there it is the reveal his son is Yamato
disproving a bunch of theories of who he
could have been talking about in the
last chapter we also get more info on
Yamato besides his name Black Maria
comments that bringing him back is a
difficult task implying that he might be
hard to find but also probably that he's
strong and even all six of them would
have trouble with him this suggests that
kind of son might truly be a beast
pun intended it appears kaido's secret
announcement is also related to a son
who black maria refers to as young
master Yamato clearly showing respect to
him in his position in the Beast pirates
hierarchy ulti is just like who cares
that's your family issue your problem
and again page one is like dang girl
relax he clearly worries enough were to
both of them it's revealed that the
prize for bringing the son back safe and
sound will be a shot for them all to go
against an all-star obviously implying
that if they win they could become one
this is a huge deal and we see that some
flying six members are clearly viewing
themselves as being on an all-star level
hopefully we'll get to find out soon
enough if it's just arrogance or if it's
coming from a real place I think Jack is
probably the weak link here since he had
trouble with in washy
nakooma mushi and Akira so if who's who
or Sasaki are as strong as they seem to
believe they are they may well have a
shot Jack says he doesn't have a problem
with it but I don't know I think he
might be a little worried here he looks
serious
as who's-who grins from ear to ear
clearly excited we go back to the
general partying and excess and we see
Luffy looking for kid not just that but
he's literally using a guy's head as a
watchtower clearly this dude does not
know how to blend in and be careful
Luffy gets soup spilled on him and that
is not good a guy comments that they
made too much soup another says throw it
away because it is too sweet or give it
to the people of aquaboy a town where
Toulouse tea house is located they say
how these people would lick the food off
the floor and say thank you they comment
on how beggars should be grateful to be
alive
while Luffy remembers Tama and how
hungry she was and how much delight she
took in any food she could get the
contrast is huge these guys wasting
perfectly good food while looking down
and insulting the people suffering who
would take joy in any food that would
help them survive Luffy serious face
comes on and we're told a luffy is angry
now you know that he's going to go crazy
in the next chapter and that whole blend
in plan is gonna fly completely out of
the window when Luffy makes those
serious expressions we usually get some
very epic moments so I really can't wait
there is so much to look forward to
Kaido son the match between the flying
six and headliners Luffy Nami and
Robbins outfits and the location of
Zorro I really can't wait and one piece
will be on break next week but the next
chapter is surely going to be epic and
eventful as always let me know your
thoughts on
chapter in the comments and let me know
what you think is going to happen next
share all your theories if you enjoyed
the vid make sure to smash that like
button until it's blue and share this
video if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification belt or you will
miss future one piece videos remember
you can get one piece reviews like this
one and other reviews early by following
our podcast anime up Rodeo links in the
description
lastly the YouTube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime uproar patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive these YouTube issues
and who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by lord
tweto himself Efrain a and the one to
your patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans steven and radha
aloha autumn the world steelers tyson
Kirino acquire respect potato Jonathan
King deci d brandon of aisles and
emperor otaku and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatoly Kazan Sookie angel Cruz
I Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no Ted Joe
Stanton very Gucci Alicia actor animal
69 Jessica Calif on he no commie and
water
Bonnie parks is OD r12 wrath oh and a
hora Tian Wong Mitch loves anime and
JCCC waka thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
an Emir or and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to a
private page and only this court where
we talked about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
slash anime up for link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the YouTube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]